The financial world is constantly changing
with the advancing digitalization in the 21st century.
This process has accelerated rapidly,
opening up new opportunities
to think about finance differently.
Digital currencies such as Bitcoin and CO
shake the world positively and negatively.
The concept of tokenization opens
a new chapter in the history of capital investment.
Decentralized, democratic, controllable, nonstop.
These are the promises of tokenization.
But what are tokens anyway?
And how do they work?
Moconomy takes a look at the complex world of tokens,
examines theory versus practice, and talks
to experts from the crypto and fintech scene.
As early as about 5000 years ago,
people traded by exchanging goods or services
Over time,
Opportunities developed to also
trade shares in goods or services
and even sell them to the public in order to raise capital.
This is how the stock markets
came into being, where companies
offer individual small company
shares to a variety of investors to invest
in the future of the company.
This need for shareholding has increased more and more
and ultimately developed into the global financial market.
Tokenization meets this need in an even more extreme way.
This is because tokenization is a further segmentation
of a unit or component into other individual components,
a kind of fractionalization.
For example, shares can also be further fractured
and the resulting units can in turn be traded.
However, the special
and new thing about tokenization is not the segmentation,
but its linking with another process
that makes tokenization interesting in the first place.
The digital and decentralized storage
of the fractions on a blockchain.
Individual sectors of the market for tokenized
assets are currently still in a kind of discovery
or experimentation phase.
Its value is estimated at less than $20 billion.
The value of the total market for digital assets
is about 350 billion USD.
This is where the enormous growth potential becomes clear.
Tokenization and blockchain technology
could fundamentally change the financial and banking sector.
By 2027,
This growth will increase dramatically to an estimated $6.9 billion.
FinTech is one of the biggest players
that will shake up the digital token game. In 2022,
The United States held the largest market share.
But what is tokenization?
How do all these new token based players
operate in the fintech market?
What is their agenda and what are their products?
In Europe,
Luxembourg based Tokeny Solutions
is one of the market leaders
in providing an institutional
and modular end to end platform
that enables the issuance, transfer and management
of tradable digital assets and security tokens
such as tokenized loans,
structured debt, securities stocks and funds.
This private B2B company provides an end to end platform
for the unified Issuance management and trading of service
and security tokens.
The company valuation for Tokeny Solutions
ranges from 22 to 33 million dollars,
with a revenue estimate of $6.5 million for the year
and a fund of $11 million.
The company uses
Etherium and Polygon's blockchain technology
and works with the RC 3643 token standard.
Another interesting player in the European
market is the Berlin based company BitBond.
They have launched
the first security token offering in Europe.
This was approved by the German financial regulator
Bafin in 2019.
BitBond is a technology provider
for the tokenization infrastructure of digital assets.
Their WEB3 product token tool
allows their customers to create,
manage and distribute tokens and NFTs through EVM chains.
The BitBond token or BB One is a security
bond token that can be purchased with Bitcoin,
Etherium, Stellar or Euro.
The value per token is equal to €1.
Their global market share
is currently less than 0.1%,
But with a team size of less than 50 people,
it is valued at around 16 to 19
million US dollar as a company.
BitBond is a private company
with a capital of $13.2 million.
Its revenues will be around 2 million U.S.
dollars in 2023.
But how does it work exactly?
BitBond uses the RC 20 token standard.
This is the most commonly used
security token in the fintech industry.
He stands for tokenized assets that comply with current
regulations for securities in the form of a token
and through a company such as BitBond or Tokeny Solutions,
The buyer can buy and trade such a security as a token.
The acquired token is implemented on a blockchain.
These blockchains are called Etherium or Polygon.
I'm Radoslav Albrecht, founder and CEO of BitBond.
A token is a term that has been around for a long time
and it basically stands for the fact that an object
or digital goods stands for something else.
For example, if you go to a funfair and pay admission,
you often get a token, a plastic chip,
which you then hand in in the carousel, for example.
And that's where the term originally comes from here.
My name is Markus Kluge.
I am a co-founder of Tokenforge.
Is the best known standard
is the RC20 token standard.
It's basically just a small register
in which anyone who has received a token
there is granted access and is the only one
who can move it with a private key.
This is what is meant by tokenization in the blockchain,
and that's what happens without regulations
and without access
from any administrator
or from any regulated party with a high risk
that if you lose your private key,
you won't be able to access that token
and you won't be able to move it,
you won't be able to sell it.
From a technical point of view,
A token is basically a database entry
and it says which address.
Which is basically the digital place
where a token is stored.
How many pieces?
How many tokens it has?
And this is implemented by what is called program code,
which in the context of blockchains is also called
smart contracts.
But basically it is program code that describes
what the technical properties of the token
are and who owns the token and who holds these tokens.
It is crucial for tokenization,
which involves creating database
entries connected to specific token owner rights
to have a register or database where the entries
can be easily read and securely stored.
The RC20 standard fulfills this function
and is implemented on a blockchain ensuring security.
Token represents a value or service.
They have been present since approximately 2014 or 2015,
when Etherium blockchain was developed, the first blockchain
where digital assets such as tokens could be created.
This initiated the development of digital tokens
and since then
the term has been in use within financial technology.
Now, with blockchain technology
using cryptography and signatures,
individuals can take more personal responsibility.
This is because all participants
can verify the ownership and transfer of assets.
The private key public pair ensures
the secure transfer of these assets.
Cryptocurrencies are also tokens created
and managed by companies or other entities
rather than institutions.
Technically, cryptocurrencies are not currencies,
but function as digital assets
that allow for exchange and trade.
These digital assets are generated
through initial COIN offerings. ICOs
The inaugural initial coin offering
was of Ethyriums creation
introducing the technical token concept for commercial use.
Subsequently, many other companies leveraged
these technical capabilities and issued additional tokens.
My name is Erwin Voloder.
I am the head of policy for the European
Blockchain Association.
If you want to buy the argument
that crypto is political, I think it is,
and I think it's been political since the Genesis block.
So if you if you look at
actually what's inscribed in the Genesis blocks
of the first block of the Bitcoin blockchain,
its chancellor on the brink.
Second bailout to banks, right?
This was during the height of the 2008 financial crisis.
And specifically, you know,
you can look at the genesis block as a picket sign.
It was it was a protest really against
what many people viewed as financial injustices
that were incurred at the cost of the people
for the benefit, at the cost of the majority,
for the benefit of a minority.
Tokenization and cryptocurrencies are shaping
a new section of the capital investment history.
This innovative investment method is transforming society,
politics and markets.
The innovative concept
allows the division of assets into numerous small fractions.
Although not a new concept.
Fractional ownership is consistently popular
in financial instruments.
Companies have historically been divided
into smaller fractions through shares or funds.
Yet the novel aspect is registering
these fractions as digital tokens on a blockchain
From a technical perspective,
there are three primary standards
that dominate the industry,
although numerous others exist.
These three can effectively map all use cases.
Companies utilizing this technology
then produce tokens of which there are thousands.
While there are approximately 5 million
distinct tokens presently in circulation,
they are all based on the same technical standards.
However, various values can be represented using them.
For instance, Stablecoins are a type of digital currency
that represent fiat currencies like the euro and the dollar.
Additionally, tokens can represent securities,
including bonds or shares.
Tokenization allows you to transfer value
with a technical substrate
that enables the removal of a lot of different frictions,
and these frictions also lead to cost reductions.
So instantaneous settlement, fractionalization.
It opens up the door for new use cases
like paper use models, streaming money,
and generally the ability to take real world assets
and represent them in a digitalized form
and then offer them to investors
and new ways to package financial products.
The ability to ease frictions in cross-border
payments as well from institutional perspective.
And I think also what's very important is tokenization
and tokenization within blockchain has the ability to
produce a higher level
of financial agency and financial inclusion,
which I think is ultimately really important.
Otherwise, why are we doing all of this?
All assets can be digitized and standardized.
Enhancing liquidity and transparency.
Automation of processes is now possible
Software developers have been considering ways to standardize tokens,
and the importance of doing so lies
in the fact that tokens are held in digital wallets
and not every wallet can store every type of token.
Therefore, it has been suggested
that a standard should be established to enable wallets
to support as many types of tokens as possible.
Developers proposed open source software
and the market adopted particular technical standards
based on their effectiveness.
These standards have become prevalent
with two dominant token variants
the RC 20 standard for fungible tokens
and the IOC 721 standard for non fungible tokens.
These ideas initially suggested
by developers have since become indispensable
and are widely used throughout the world.
But the true highlight of tokenization
lies in the affordable entry prices for investors
that are associated with the smaller stakes.
The one challenge that
that blockchain crypto or
I should say that crypto faces
and you see this in decentralized finance is the
end user or the user experience, right.
Using these financial products
and services is oftentimes
tricky and challenging or requires
a certain level of technical literacy that not everyone has.
And also at the end of the day,
it's generally driven by interest.
I don't think you can make the argument
and say that everyone will use this all the time
everywhere, because that isn't the case with anything now.
So why would it be any different?
Human nature is a fickle thing.
So I think that the point should be to make it
as easy to use as possible,
as frictionless, as seamless as possible.
Issuers can save money through tokenization,
which enables them to access funds directly without the need
for an intermediary, thus eliminating the high fees
associated with working with investment banks
or other institutions.
I'm Elizabeth Resnick.
I'm an economist by background, and to this day
I help basically crypto asset service providers,
law firm, consulting firm
and navigate through this new European
regulatory regime that we have in crypto asset,
which we call market in crypto asset.
The MICA is an EU legal framework for cryptocurrencies
and tokens that are traded on digital platforms.
It replaces the individual regulations
of the individual countries.
The MICA basically aims
to target some specific assets in the crypto,
the crypto industry
and certain services linked to those crypto assets.
So if we take the parallelism
to the traditional financial sector, we have MiFID,
which cover financial instruments.
Now we have Mica that covers some type of crypto assets
which are in three big categories,
which are the Stablecoins
and the other crypto assets, including utility token.
With the implementation of the markets
and crypto assets Regulation called MICA,
a consistent EU wide framework has been established.
So it will change a lot of things in the
in the regulatory landscape
and also in the crypto industry itself, because as we know,
all the continents have their own approach
or sometimes we don't have any approach at all.
So I think it will change a lot of things
and also within the financial sector as well. Why?
Because the traditional financial sector so far,
if you go to a bank and you want to buy Bitcoin,
your banker will most likely refuse this request.
Some of them, they jump on board it,
but 99% will say, no, we don't do it.
After Mica comes into force
right now, what they can do is actually
they can offer those services
without even having the MICA license,
which can be quite a bit of polemic
because it's not because you're a bank
or financial institutions that you can actually understand,
that you have the experience
and your knowledge to provide those services.
Cryptocurrencies are traded via crypto exchanges.
Utility tokens represent a specific
benefit or functionality on a platform.
There are different types of tokens
that can serve as financial instruments,
Security tokens Act as digital securities.
They can have the characteristics of shares or bonds.
A Security token, usually certify as a security.
It is technically referred to as the RC20 token
and is similar to a fungible token
with some additional features.
It is crucial to identify the token holders for securities
and specific technical settings can be implemented
to restrict the transaction of these tokens
to a particular whitelist of recipient
by approving which recipients can hold the token,
you are indicating their authorization.
Security tokens are commonly designed
this way as issuers usually need to know
and sometimes may be legally mandated to know
the owner of the tokens.
Utility tokens on the other hand,
refer to tokens that operate
as platforms or specific currencies.
Imagine that, for instance, you do not
utilize standard currency on social media,
but a token that has been developed,
particularly for these platforms.
And subsequently
you can exchange this token
for certain features on the platform.
The process of tokenization starts with gathering
objective information about the asset.
This may involve obtaining
a detailed depiction of a property
or an inventory of artworks within a collection,
along with their specific attributes.
The collected data is then digitized and securely stored.
A unique token is subsequently created that represents
the ownership rights to the physical asset being described.
The digital token is securely stored on the blockchain,
and owing to this specific information, bears
a distinct digital signature of the asset.
There is considerable opposition
because it represents a new technology
and a paradigm shift in approach.
Previously, when moving a security from A to B, physical
transfer was necessary, hence the creation of securities.
Now, however, there is only a register.
It is sufficient to modify access
rights to a token and transfer it.
In essence, the security is now linked to the asset
and no longer a freely transferable security.
This change has various consequences
for the processes involved.
Our current objective
is to integrate all the available technologies
such as digital identities, digital currencies,
and tokenization in a manner that achieves
genuine democratized access.
Once a token has been created and saved on a blockchain,
it can be managed through smart contracts.
Smart contracts allow for rent payments
to be transferred to an investor
in proportion to their investment
as soon as the rent is received.
Alternatively, a smart contract
can automatically trigger payments once
specific project milestones are reached.
The interesting thing about token
is you could say it's a smart contract
that is registered on a blockchain,
but in the end we talk about programable values.
I don't want to say money here
because there might be a difference between money
and its regulation and transferable values,
but it will be very important.
For example, if we think about sustainability,
that we not only introduce a new digital asset,
but that it generates impact.
So we need to add meaning to a certain nominal factor.
And this will be,
I think, the most relevant aspect of tokenization
that we create digital units for whatever underlying asset,
but that we can optimize its use, we can incentivize
certain behaviors.
Investment in tokenized real estate represents
one of the most recent advancements in the property
industry.
Tokenization enables houses and apartments
to be divided and sold in numerous smaller units.
Small programs
act as a bridge between the property
and an online trading platform.
Hence, tokens create a digital representation of a property
facilitating its digital transfer.
Many potential investors
either unwilling to enter this market on a large scale
or unable to do so due to factors such as lack of equity
or difficulties in obtaining debt financing.
The concept of tokenization offers a significant advantage
by enabling the smallest unit of investment
to be acquired at a much lower threshold.
For instance, a flat owner, could split a property
worth €100,000 into 1000 tokens.
Each token would be valued at €100,
representing a small portion of the flat.
Investors would then hold the
rights to a particular percentage
of rental income with each token.
After deducting costs like property tax repairs
and insurance, investors stand to profit
as the apartment increases in value over time
and rental income grows.
Another benefit of tokenization is the ability
to convert the individual tokens any time.
24 seven via apps or trading platforms that form.
Furthermore, the need to visit a notary
and have the property or share notarized before
purchasing is eliminated.
Purchasers can efficiently manage
their tokens through a mobile wallet application.
The app's features may vary depending on its design,
allowing users to track their incoming payments.
Monitor token value fluctuations via a chart
displays and sell tokens through their smartphones.
Real estate tokens follow similar regulations to securities
and do not provide physical ownership
of the underlying property.
Essentially, a real estate token functions as a loan
that the provider utilizes for property financing.
The loans interest is covered by the rental income,
which poses a risk of loss, the possibility of rent defaults
and in extreme cases, the provider's insolvency increases
this risk as compared
to investing through a property fund
which is usually diversified across many properties.
In Germany,
Such a scenario isn't yet to be realized
due to the absence of a regulatory framework
that facilitates
securitization of property rights associated with land
and real estate.
The process of purchasing a property
is still associated with significant bureaucracy,
lengthy procedures and subsequent high costs.
Digital art projects were the
first to bring tokenization to public attention.
With this assistance of non-fungible tokens,
digital art pieces are typically secured as a whole
in the blockchain.
In March 2021, American artist Beeple sold a digital collage
comprising 5000 individual images
for an extraordinary 69.35 million USD at an auction.
The single tweet by Jack Dorsey, founder of Twitter,
was purchased by a fan for an impressive
sum of 2.9 million USD.
My name is Everfresh, also known as Sebastian Pfeifer.
So that's my real name.
We are not going to see anything like we've seen in 2021
so that that ship has sailed.
My hope actually is that
the market will reach a more mature state
where price levels are reasonable
and artists can actually live
off their art sales in that digital space.
It's never going to be everyone
That's clear but that's not how it how it works.
So it's always just going to be a few
that will be able to make a living out of it.
If you look at the sheer numbers,
the people collecting crypto art
is growing and growing and growing.
My name is Sergio Schmoldt.
I'm the founder and CEO of MAGALL
MAGALL stands for Meta Art Gallery.
There is, of course, the 2021 Jan Bubble
where you had a crypto art NFT market
explosion with 14.000%.
If you have such a high increase,
you fall down very, very briefly.
So what we are doing right now,
we are trying to get a new base
level and from that level
we can progress together with crypto,
together
with Bitcoin, together with everything that is behind it.
Art tokens may be obtained from any location worldwide
allowing for international investment in the art industry.
Twitter is the main platform to promote your stuff
in the NFT world
and you can also use other social media platforms.
But Twitter is by far the one with the most impact.
I reach my audience mainly through Twitter.
Of course, I promote my work
on other social media platforms as well,
but I've not noticed any correlation
directly to sales through other platforms than Twitter.
I would say the biggest trend right now is the thing that we are doing
coming from the metaverse and coming into in real life.
So you can only feel crypto art if you can touch it,
if you can see it like here.
On our screens and this is
the step that the gallerist needs to do.
With the assistance of Nonfungible tokens.
Digital art pieces are typically secured
as a whole in the blockchain, despite an artist
creating multiple NFT of an identical image,
each NFT possesses a distinct identity
within the blockchain.
And that means these tokens are essentially unique.
We can illustrate this concept by considering a €1 coin.
When we hold this coin in our hand,
we do not distinguish it from any other €1 coin
as they have identical purchasing power.
Such coins are referred to as fungible.
The same principle applies to securities such as BMW shares.
We do not differentiate between individual shares
as they are fungible.
The BMW share represents identical voting rights and value.
Non-Fungible tokens,
NFT can be likened to artworks
such as owning a unique Picasso painting or the Mona Lisa.
While forgeries may exist, the genuine Mona
Lisa is one of a kind and nonfungible
with no other exact copies.
Art also employs the concept of limited edition prints
where a photo may have, for instance, only 100 copies,
each with a unique number.
These numbered prints belong to a specific series,
although numerous tokens can be used.
The idea is for each token to be exclusively identified,
but on the other hand, fungible security
tokens are identical and can be exchanged for each other.
So you have some
gray area.
I would say also regarding NFT.
So we have defi NFT on the covers and all part of tokens.
However, the really it's not because
you call something an NFT that it won't be on the MICA.
So they're really mentioning that
if something is issue in a large series,
it's an indicator of different abilities.
So then it doesn't necessarily mean it will be an NFT.
But again, what is a large series, we don't know yet.
So we hope
we'll have some clarification down the road.
But so those little things we can play with words
you don't know, especially
that the technology evolves so quickly.
Most NFT sales are actually auctions.
They are not auctions in the classical sense
where there's like a guy with a hammer.
But it's just you
usually put your piece on a platform or
with a with the reserve.
And once the reserve is met,
then there's like
you can define that how long the auction goes.
But usually it's like a 24 hour auction
and then the timer starts and it runs for 24 hours.
And then it depends if other people
put in their bids as well, if the price goes up or not.
Most platforms take between five and 15%.
Some also take 20.
Most take between five and 15%.
Tokenization can be a useful tool
for making art accessible to a large audience.
It simplifies the process of investing in art,
making it easy, safe and reliable for artists themselves.
Is tokenization a promising way to sell art work?
In theory, artists could even offer themselves
as capital investments to investors.
As a result, artists can generate a steady stream
of additional income if their value increases.
Investors will earn a profit.
The art market remains considerably unclear,
necessitating a thorough knowledge of the players,
the influencing factors and the dynamics of this market
in order to be competitive when buying works of art.
Our collection of works from the top 100 artists
is usually unavailable at local galleries
but is sourced from the leading international galleries
without access, art work becomes either
unobtainable or extremely expensive
due to multiple trade flows,
each resulting in price increases.
Fractional ownership of an asset in the art
industry is demonstrated through art security tokens ASTs
these digital assets correspond to a portion of an art work.
Previously, this market was exclusive to the super rich
due to the exorbitant prices of art.
Prices are often in the millions
which few can afford.
But our trade is changing that we possess
a meticulous network of art experts who identify
appealing works on your behalf.
The entire process involves
a complex data analysis procedure.
We digitally store all the relevant information
as each artwork is assigned a single digital security,
which comes in the form of a security token.
The value of one token corresponds
to €1 of the artworks you value.
In essence, this is a fully regulated digital security.
As per the new electronic securities Act.
This allows us to treat the token and the security
similarly to other conventional securities,
ultimately facilitating their integration
into the financial industry's infrastructure,
Thanks to their assistance,
anyone can now invest in works of art
that would typically be excluded from an average investors
portfolio.
Under normal circumstances.
You can invest in these works
of art indirectly with as little as €1,000
by purchasing these tokens.
This ensures that our enthusiasts with smaller
budgets can engage in magnificent art projects.
Even the classic art works
are now available on the blockchain.
Most recently, a blockchain token was created for Pablo
Picasso's renowned masterpiece, Fillette Beret.
The responsibility for the tokenization
fell upon a crypto bank situated in Zurich,
which split
the oil painting into 4000 individual art tokens,
each valued at 1,000 CHF.
These tokens were subsequently transformed
into blockchain based securities
that offer a clear cut legal right to the original
and one of a kind
painting dating back to 1964 in Switzerland.
As an investor,
you do not acquire a piece of the artwork itself,
but rather a securitized claim
to participate in its performance.
We made a conscious choice to avoid fractional ownership
and instead opt for a security
as it aligns with a traditional investment product
and can seamlessly integrate into the financial system.
When works are traded
on the secondary market, often after a prior purchase,
the artist or artists typically do not participate further.
However,
we aim to expand this model in the long term
by exploring the potential of structuring
tokens and smart contracts.
Currently, this concept remains uncertain.
This would allow the artists to maintain a permanent
stake in the value development of their artwork
through a percentage of ownership.
I see a very bright future when I look at my kids.
The things they collect, Fortnite skins
or some digital weapons for a game.
This kind of collection
feeling is
as parallel to crypto art collection, so people will
not hang a Picasso
in oil painting on their wall.
My kids will not do it.
They will collect other art
and this may be the idea that they are collecting.
Large art galleries,
museums, collections and storage facilities for works of art
may benefit from tokenization in the near future.
These institutions
invest considerable sums in protecting their works
of art against theft and vandalism,
which is a costly undertaking.
Museums often lack sufficient funding through entrance fees
and other sources to expand their collections.
Tokenization has the potential to provide
much needed liquidity.
It could potentially provide investors
with the opportunity to profit
from the increased value of the art work
by making the collection
or a portion of it available for investment.
A share represents the security that a company issues
depending on the kind of share, it may entitle the holder
to a portion of the profits, dividends or voting rights.
Companies issue shares in order to raise funds
their business development.
However, despite advancements in digitalization,
trading in shares remains inefficient in many areas.
In the event that you wish to invest in shares,
buying an entire share is typical an accessory.
Yet shares from large firms often cost more than 1,000 USD.
This narrows the pool of individuals
who can accommodate its cost.
Moreover, obtaining ownership in a few major
corporations constrains
your potential for portfolio diversification
through investment in multiple shares.
My name is Philipp Pieper.
I'm the founder of Swarm.
We are a tokenization platform
that does both primary issuance
as well as secondary trading.
In the past two years
there has been obviously
a very high degree of focus on crypto assets.
So basically, you know, Bitcoin and derivatives of Bitcoin
as well as sort of other native assets
that were on sort of the blockchain like Ethereum.
But it's been shown obviously that there's
a very high degree of correlation amongst all these assets.
So if the market goes up, everything goes up.
If the market goes down and crashes
down, everything goes down.
So in that world,
there is a need to actually have
something called real world assets replicated onto chain
which actually derive the value of what they are
from the underlying asset
that is connected with that kind of digital asset.
So a good example of that is basically a stablecoin.
Tokenization enables
the purchase of fractional shares in large companies
rather than obtaining an entire share.
Partial purchases can be made to generate
a proportional yield.
Digital securities can be created through
tokenization referred to as token derivatives,
which are secured on the blockchain
and thus embedded in a more versatile infrastructure.
Essentially, shareholders receive a conventional share,
but with benefits aligned with cryptocurrencies.
The value of the tokenized share
is always equivalent to the share price
of the company that issued it.
If the value of the deposited charitable,
then the tokenized shares value also doubles.
The price analysis of tokenized shares
is like that of shares as opposed to cryptocurrency fees.
So Stablecoin is effectively a token
that represents maybe a dollar.
So one token equals $1,
you should actually have the ability
to put anything that has value,
anything that has some kind of substance
onto the blockchain, into these trading
environments, into the ability
to functionally and mobilize these assets.
There's a very large
realm of different asset qualities
that you can gain
by putting them as a digital asset onto chain.
So if you have one Apple stock
that is represented in one token,
while you can buy a cent of the Apple
stock, if you want to
that you cannot do in the traditional markets.
Tokenization significantly reduces the barriers
to entry into the new financial markets.
The majority of all companies worldwide
are presently private companies.
So there's derivative products
that probably mimic some of that,
but it's not the degree of flexibility.
The second thing is that you actually have
a an immediate settlement.
So if I go on to one,
some kind of exchange, some kind of decentralized exchange,
some kind of trading venue, and you and I agree on a price
actually by executing on the blockchain immediately,
the transfer of my ownership to you has been executed
normally in the financial markets.
That takes 2 to 3 days to settle.
From regulatory perspective.
The United States is also in a unique position
because of the dollar.
So, you know, the dollar is
is famously once said
that the dollar is the United States currency,
but everyone else's problem
really, I don't fully buy that argument.
I think that the dollar is also the United States
problem now,
because you have jurisdictions in other parts of the world
that are essentially creating regulation
for digital US dollars in the future.
And none of this is coming from the US yet.
So, you know, regulating
stablecoins is one of the lower hanging fruit
that they could
that they could tackle in terms of,
you know, reasserting this position of the dollar hegemony.
And this is not a
this is not a position that Europe has to the same degree.
I mean, you know, the US dollar
still makes up something like 60% of global reserve.
The United States political system is also, by design,
an invitation to struggle.
And it has been since the Declaration of Independence.
So you always have to know that
when you're looking at the US,
I always have to think of this.
The tokenized share serve as a link between
conventional stock exchanges such as Zetra
or the Frankfurt Stock Exchange
and a cryptocurrency exchange like Binance.
Token transactions can be processed in mere minutes,
contingent on the network and crypto exchange.
If you have the
ability to trade on a 24 seven basis
without any kind of stoppage of the markets,
it's a benefit.
It actually means real money for people.
If you can attach governance processes
to these technical things,
it is a benefit
because you have a much more real time interaction
with the way that the asset down
below can actually transact.
But even more so if you actually then have the confidence,
which means that you have some data that is
that is connected with the token
that points to where it actually goes
and what it represents and the live data
reporting what it actually has in terms of values.
Then suddenly you're not reliant on a quarterly report,
but you have a real time view on it.
As smart contracts perform, buy
and sell orders of tokens on a blockchain,
there's no longer need to rely on a broker or
banker as an intermediary.
So I would say that broadly, those would be some of the
some of the aspects where we're tokenization
will transform the financial industry.
Whether or not you buy
that there will be a complete removal of intermediaries.
It will certainly, you know, limit
the role of intermediaries,
diminish the frequency of intermediaries
in certain financial transactions.
In the world of tokenization, in the end,
it all represents
something that has some kind of resemblance in real life.
So there's a trust element that needs to be created,
which also means that if the token gets lost,
it really depends on how you set it up.
You can actually sort of then make sure that it's either,
you know, respecting who the real owner is so,
you know, or basically gets redistributed
back to the original owner.
It's just an efficiency technology.
Selling company shares involves
lots of people and takes a while due to bureaucracy.
We need to unite the technical possibilities
in the traditional world.
The latter insists on maintaining the status quo
as it has proven stable over the last few decades.
There are stakeholders who profit from this naturally,
and conversely, the DEFI and crypto community
advocates for self-determination in every aspect.
However The reality likely lies
somewhere between these extremes,
and we must construct accordingly.
Investors cannot access these companies.
Financial institutions usually invest in these companies
using costly loans or investment funds.
Thus, the market experiences low levels of liquidity.
Yes, I think it will affect more the B2B space
because for us as end users,
we are interested in usability and of course trust,
but we are not necessarily interested
if a banking or fintech app
is using technology A or technology B,
especially if we talk about mass adoption,
then this should not play a role.
It should be a well-performing app.
Investors usually make long term investments.
However, if the company management changes its direction,
it is not easy for investors to exit.
In such cases, they may attempt
to influence the company management.
Just to think of this as
well, it's an open system and therefore everyone has access.
That's also not entirely true.
It means that depending how you set up the system
and that very much depends on what asset it represents,
you have restrictions
that you artificially have to build into the system
that only a certain type of customer
can buy into those specific asset tokens,
or that there's only a certain behavior
that is allowed to be executed with the token.
So there's a there is a very much a technology
enforced restriction, but what it gives you is actually
a much higher degree of confidence
from a regulatory process as well.
That because it's code
and because it's actually
enforcing what the code is being told to do,
that, you know, you cannot really bypass it.
We expect
tokenization and blockchain technology
to play a role to design more efficient
and streamlined processes.
So that's step number one.
Then we will potentially tokenize
and also use blockchain technology
to finance in different ways
and to tokenize different assets.
So that's, let's say, a growth aspect
depending on regulation, but also on, let's say,
strategic decisions, some fully automated
neo blockchain banks or neo
blockchain players on the market,
we can expect that new use cases
and a whole new set of process designs
will see the day of light.
So this means a totally new category
targeting new use cases that are not right there available.
Discussions regarding the energy industry's future
increasingly center around energy tokenization.
Renewable energies have grown
increasingly popular in our current era.
Wind and solar parks continue
to attract a growing number of investors.
My name is Ekow.
I am CEO of Real Port.
Decentralization of Energy
is already there and it's only going to accelerate.
I think the past years
considering the Ukraine war and considering
this drive of governments
and our society to become more independent has shown
an incredible boom of rooftop solar and decentralized energy
so as not only the companies
and the supply chains grow more mature,
it's going to be even easier for
for tenants of houses and for owners of houses
in order to, number one, put solar into the roof.
And then it's a matter of connecting that
amongst the various decentralized hubs,
meaning from one roof
to another and into the grid in a smart way.
And I do think that technology can play fantastic.
The energy sector's intricate network is hindered
by outdated
infrastructure and numerous inefficient processes.
Utilizing blockchain
can enhance the efficiency of the energy supply.
And efficiency means saving costs.
Saving costs means that you can bring in smaller projects.
In smaller projects
also means that you can bring in small investors,
speakers advantages for the smaller guys, it's
making it more efficient, making access more efficient,
and also enabling smaller wind farms
in order to participate within the energy economy.
Thanks to its decentralized architecture,
it can document the supply chains of multiple energy
producers simultaneously,
which is a much more complex process
with centralized systems
in such systems, every producer has to first
send their data to a central location
for bundling and processing
in a decentralized blockchain network.
Anyone can feed the data directly
by means of tokenization.
A digital copy of each physical energy unit
can be stored on a blockchain.
This automation of administrative processes
can significantly reduce the cost of energy.
You know, the way we see that two different forms
one form is sharing the economic performance
out of an energy project
or part of a renewable energy project.
That means a generator wants to set up
a wind farm and needs investors
right, and will promise essentially the proceeds of this
wind farm to be shared amongst investors.
So now we can tokenize essentially the future proceeds
of this investment and invest of this project
with multiple investors.
So that's one part.
And the much more difficult part is
how do we certify renewable energy
through national agencies
and make it fungible or tradable in a sense.
Blockchain technology
allows for the tracing of energy from the source to the end Consumer.
Certificates can be issued if required for proof of purchase.
This can be a crucial factor, particularly
considering the stringent regulations for renewable energy.
Currently, it is difficult to ascertain
whether the energy derives from wind, solar
or another source.
A third party is required to certify the origin,
and these certificates may be traded.
Greenwashing is facilitated.
There is various
legislative and also regulatory aspects around that.
Number one is the EU taxonomy, which now
date tells us what is green, what is not green.
So that gives guidance to investors
and also to the issuers of financial products.
And number two, there is also a self
disclosure regulation called SFDR.
So every publisher or every issuer of financial products
will need to self-assess
whether they are highly sustainable Article
nine or not sustainable, basically Article seven.
And that will give consumers
tremendous guidance as to what is green, what is not green.
So that means the leeway to kind of move around
and kind of greenwash as to becoming a whole lot smaller.
Tokenized certificates can be produced by the supplier,
providing an indisputable origin of the energy generated.
These certificates are securely stored in the blockchain,
ensuring that the data cannot be altered.
Governance tokens are a particular
type of token that some companies issue,
especially those in the technology field, or what are called
decentralized autonomous organizations.
These tokens grant certain rights to their owners
in terms of technicalities.
They are often the RC20 tokens
following the standard that many other token types
adhere to,
but the rights they confirm may differ from securities
tokens.
For example,
voting rights are frequently represented
by governance tokens,
which are also used by companies
and owned by those who purchase them.
By possessing governance tokens.
I am granted the right to vote on certain matters.
If a company wishes to make changes such as implementing
technical modifications, token holders have a say.
And this means that not only do I get money
if I keep this token and expect
to make a profit in the future,
but I also have a say in how things are done.
I can join communities where my opinion counts,
depending on how many tokens I have.
Now the big challenge realize
how do consumers, be it a business, consumer
or even a regular retail consumer
buy into certificated or to certified
renewable energy sources?
And that's where a blockchain can provide a huge benefit.
And the vision is that eventually you'll be able
to match certificates at the time of production
with consumption at the time when you really needed.
Tokenization will increasingly facilitate investment
into wind farms and other renewable energy sources.
The process of investing in a solar park
using tokens will soon become common practice.
The same principle will apply to the purchasing
of electricity from various energy sources,
specifically in the field of solar energy.
The initial suppliers have already
implemented the tokenization of their plants.
There are also wind power plant platforms
that connect plant operators
with companies and private individuals.
Tokenization
allows token owners to become co-owners of a wind turbine
and generate proportional returns by selling
the generated electricity.
Additionally, plant operators benefit from tokenization.
Cincy provides
another opportunity to directly collect capital
for the plant, giving them access to high liquidity.
However, the management of energy
is still largely centralized.
There is considerable progress to be made
before the new technology is widely adopted.
The next step is now connecting neighborhoods
the same way as larger projects of renewable energies
are now participating entire communities
in exchange for the permission of erecting a solar farm
or a wind farm
into participating into that right into the
into the consumption of the energy which is being produced.
And that will also create communities
which will be able to dispatch
and to trade energy amongst themselves
and amongst multiple communities.
So, yes, it's on the way. Difficult to say really, Right.
I think, you
know, Germany is probably the largest in Europe,
rooftop solar market in that.
And that in that respects has to has the most installations.
But you see this trend everywhere.
You see France has very, very strong regulation
and in the UK and Italy as well as well,
I think you can be a must see it as a pan-European move.
The demand for sustainably and ethically sourced
products has been increasing in recent years,
with society calling for greater transparency
in supply chains.
Tokenizing the supply chain is a key step in ensuring
credible product transparency for consumers in line
with growing concerns for sustainability,
human rights and animal welfare.
Tokenizing the supply chain is a key
step in ensuring credible product transparency
for consumers.
The technology shows potential, particularly in light
of the recently enacted Supply Chain Due Diligence Act,
which seeks demonstrate
that organizations have not breached their obligations
with regards to environmental and human rights.
To diligence,
it is crucial for companies to document
accurately every stage of their supply chain
to enable tracking and proving of sustainability
to both authorities and consumers.
Tokenized ocean technology has made product
tracking possible across the value chain
by using a standard smartphone.
All relevant product information
can be collected and stored in a token
which can be used through an app
for storage of any type of information.
Retrieval of any production step or raw
material is possible at any time with a reliable system.
Global supply chains can be traced with ease
by deploying blockchain technology for documentation.
Artificial intelligence
can assist in evaluating risks
by scrutinizing supplier contracts for adherence
to human rights and environmental standards.
Firms can make prompt modifications
to regulatory arrangements as required.
Tokenization in agriculture
permits farmers to convert their produce into tokens,
enabling international investors
to invest in regional agricultural commodities.
The health care industry
is using tokenization to manage confidential data
from patients and health care organizations,
While the logistics sector
is exploring a comparable concept
aiming to remedy an administrative issue
through the transfer
of the Bill of lading onto the blockchain.
So that means that we can expect
that if tokenization is becoming part
of, let's say, the underlying
process set up for financial transactions,
that the total market size will be bigger than today's
financial asset market volume.
But of course this will not happen overnight.
It will happen in different steps depending on regulation,
on innovation and on general acceptance.
We need democratic discussions
about things, need governance.
So it could take anything
between five and 20 years and it will happen in steps,
but the addressable market size will become bigger.
Although blockchain
based asset tokenization has numerous benefits
and is becoming more popular, it also has restrictions.
One disadvantage each of tokens.
Presently.
Is there scalability regarding the underlying blockchain.
If one were to tokenize all securities
currently existing in the worldwide securities market
and place them on to a blockchain,
then the blockchains would fail
to accommodate the resultant transaction
Volume.
This would cause the system
to become overloaded and overwhelmed.
The crucial drawback of tokens.
They do not adhere to a technical standard,
but rather operate on the underlying platforms.
Specifically, the blockchains where these tokens exist
There is a risk of cybercriminals accessing and stealing
digital assets.
Although blockchain technology
is believed to be highly secure,
successful attacks on cryptocurrency exchanges
and other blockchain based systems have occurred.
Typically, attackers obtained access
not through the blockchain
but through their connection points.
Therefore, it is crucial to develop a comprehensive
and dependable cybersecurity system.
I think Mica is a great first step,
so if you can think of like a global regulatory
waterfall that trickles down,
I would say that Europe is kind of sitting
at the top at the crest of this waterfall.
And I think that a lot of what we've achieved
with Mica as a continent
is now making its way into the regulatory
thinking and rationale in other jurisdictions.
Banks have traditionally acted as asset managers.
They aim to broaden their range of services
and provide customers
with the most extensive possible choice.
As a result,
they have begun to investigate the tokenization of assets.
It's possible that in the future banks
may oversee the issuance and trading of tokenized assets.
FinTech has become one of the fastest
growing industries in recent times.
One area currently undergoing significant innovation
in tokens is payment processing.
Security tokens provide a relevant example.
For instance, offer their holders regular coupons,
which may consist of an interest rate paid annually.
The token can be loaded with vast quantities of information,
enabling it to determine the amount of the interest coupon
and collect the corresponding sum from the issuer
and then distribute it automatically to the investors.
In the conventional banking industry,
a paying agent is assigned when a company releases a bond,
the paying agent.
Typically a bank, ensures that the issuer makes
timely interest payments and distributes them to investors.
This process can be automated using program
code, such as smart contracts.
With the added benefit of transferring
this information to the token.
talking about
the ecological impact of blockchains I think is a big deal,
but we as an industry
have to ask ourselves what's right and wrong, right?
A lot of people, from looking at it from the outside
then think that all that energy is the same energy mix
as the energy that goes into our daily consumption.
And as much as that was the case, it's changed dramatically.
So there's a lot of
regenerative energies that have been started to be used
the hydro energy, wind energy, but also solar energy
that basically go into these node computations.
And this is energy
that never has been used in a consumer's perspective.
So it's not competing against the energy that you and I use
in our daily lives.
More than 60% right now is already regenerative energy
that the Bitcoin network actually uses,
and the rest is still something to work on.
Financing through tokens has
the potential to significantly transform
the global economy in the future.
Companies can digitally map tangible assets
and fund them through decentralized means.
Decentralized solutions will supersede
traditional financial services.
And I think that in the future,
what we're likely going to see is on the
on the side of payments and crypto,
and we'll have different digital currency areas.
So when you could have stablecoins and
commercial bank money tokens
and different kinds of cbdcs and these will all exist
in some in cash,
So all exist in some and some as German say “Mischung”, right.
And some mixed together.
And I don't think that one will
necessarily crowd out the other.
On the other hand, I also believe that
a lot of why we see an interest in crypto
and I think globally it's about like 23%
of people globally hold crypto in Europe
I think the is on 17.
So we're still on the lower side
compared to the global average, but it's growing
and I think it's confidence, right?
So like if people don't have confidence in the system,
they look for alternatives.
And I think that's a challenge from a political perspective
for the
for the governments of nation states is
how do we instill confidence
in our systems in an age of digital transformation?
And there's no easy answer to that question.
And I think that at the same time,
it might be a little naive to assume
that crypto can solve all of the world's problems.
So I would say that we need
some sort of tempered optimism
or tailored optimism.
There is still a lack of standardization of networks
requiring the development of legal standards to provide
clarity and security for companies and investors.
So the impact of this can already be seen in our society.
With the technology already prevalent.